HIS OWN LAWYERS TO PREVENT THEM
FROM FULLY COMPLYING WITH A
FEDERAL SUBPOENA.
HERE WITH ME IS THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
JIM JORDAN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME THIS
MORNING, SIR.
THE INDICTMENT DOES SAY AS I
MENTIONED THE DOCUMENTS INCLUDED
U.S. DEFENSE, NUCLEAR
CAPABILITIES, POTENTIAL U.S.
VULNERABILITIES TO MILITARY
ATTACK.
THEY WERE KEPT IN UNSECURE AREAS
LIKE A BATHROOM, BALLROOM,
BEDROOM.
THE INDICTMENT SAYS DONALD TRUMP
LIED TO LAWYERS, HIS OWN
LAWYERS, WHICH RESULTED IN FALSE
STATEMENTS TO THE FBI SO HE
COULD KEEP THOSE DOCUMENTS.
IS ANY OF THAT ACCEPTABLE TO
YOU?
>> DANA, THE STANDARD IS CLEAR.
THE STANDARD IS NAVY VIRS EAGAN
A 1988 CASE, UNANIMOUS DECISION
FROM THE COURT THAT JUSTICE
BLACKMAN WROTE THE OPINION AND
IT SAID THE PRESIDENT'S ABILITY
TO CLASSIFY AND CONTROL ACCESS
TO NATIONAL SECURITY INFORMATION
FLOWS FROM THE CONSTITUTION.
HE DECIDES.
HE ALONE DECIDES.
HE SAID HE DECLASSIFIED THIS
MATERIAL.
HE CAN PUT IT WHEREVER HE WANTS
AND HANDLE IT HOWEVER HE WANTS.
THAT'S THE LAW.
THAT'S THE STANDARD.
JACK SMITH CAN DO ALL THIS 37
DIFFERENT COUNTS OR WHATEVER HE
WANTS TO DO BUT THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE THE STANDARD THAT THE
SUPREME COURT IN A UNANIMOUS
DECISION SAID WAS THAT.
HE CAN CLASSIFY AND HE CAN
CONTROL ACCESS.
HE HAS THE SOLE AUTHORITY.
>> IN THIS INDICTMENT HE STATES
ON AT LEAST ONE OCCASION THAT HE
DID NOT DECLASSIFY THE
INFORMATION WHEN HE IS SHOWING A
DOCUMENT TO SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T
HAVE SECURITY CLEARANCE I MIGHT
ADD.
HE SAYS, EXPLICITLY, IT IS
CLASSIFIED.
HE DIDN'T DECLASSIFY IT.
>> DANA, HE SAID TIME AND TIME
AGAIN HE DECLASSIFIED ALL THIS
MATERIAL.
THIS IS THE MOST POLITICAL THING
I HAVE EVER SEEN.
THEY HAVE BEEN OUT TO GET --
THEY ARE INDICTING PRESIDENT
TRUMP ON TUESDAY FOR HAVING
MATERIAL THAT HE DECLASSIFIED
THAT WAS PROTECTED BY THE SECRET
SERVICE.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING IT
IS THE ADMINISTRATION, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FROM HIS
OPPONENT IN THE UPCOMING
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
I MEAN, THIS IS AS POLITICAL AS
IT GETS.
FRANKLY, DANA, IT IS PART OF A
PATTERN.
WE HAVE SEEN IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WITH THE PRESIDENT OVER
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
THEY TRY ONE THING THEN THEY TRY
ANOTHER.
THEY'VE CONTINUED TO GO AFTER
HIM.
I THINK ANYONE WITH COMMON SENSE
CAN SEE THAT.
>> OKAY.
THIS IS A VERY DETAILED
INDICTMENT.
A COUPLE THINGS YOU JUST SAID.
NUMBER ONE THE SECRET SERVICE,
THEY ARE CHARGED WITH PROTECTING
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW ACCORDING
TO THE INDICTMENT THAT THE
DOCUMENTS WERE THERE.
SO THAT WASN'T THEIR JOB.
NUMBER TWO, DO YOU HAVE EVIDENCE
THAT THE PRESIDENT, WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT, NOW FORMER PRESIDENT,
ACTUALLY DECLASSIFIED THESE
DOCUMENTS BEFORE HE TOOK THEM?
>> I GO ON THE PRESIDENT'S WORD.
HE SAID HE DID.
THE SUPREME COURT SAID THAT'S
WHAT COUNTS.
WE CAN HAVE ALL THE THINGS JACK
SMITH WANTS TO SAY BUT EVERYONE
SEES THIS FOR THE POLITICAL
OPERATION IT IS.
THE STANDARD IS THE STANDARD.
I DIDN'T SET THE STANDARD.
THE CONSTITUTION AND THE SUPREME
COURT DID.
THEY DID IT IN A UNANIMOUS
FASHION AND IT WAS AN OPINION
WRITTEN BY JUSTICE BLACKMAN.
THAT IS THE STANDARD.
THAT'S THE FACT.
JACK SMITH CAN WRITE WHATEVER HE
WANTS BUT THIS IS SO POLITICAL.
IN 2016 -- I MEAN EVERY ELECTION
WE'VE NOW SEEN THIS, DANA.
2016 IT WAS A DOSSIER THEY USED.
THEY KNEW IT WAS FALSE.
THEY USED IT TO GO GET A WARRANT
TO SPY ON HIS CAMPAIGN.
2018 THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
2020 THEY SUPPRESSED THE BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY WITH THE 51 FORMER
INTEL OFFICIALS.
2022 --
>> LET ME STOP YOU RIGHT THERE,
SIR.
FIRST I WANT TO GO BACK TO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU SAID.
>> NOW THEY INDICTED HIM BEFORE
THE 2024 PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
>> ON JULY 21st, A RECORDING OF
A CONVERSATION THAT HE HAD SAID,
QUOTE, AS PRESIDENT, I COULD
HAVE DECLASSIFIED IT.
TALKING ABOUT A DOCUMENT HE WAS
HOLDING.
NOW I CAN'T.
THAT MEANS IT WASN'T
DECLASSIFIED.
BUT I WANT TO MOVE ON TO WHAT'S
IN THIS INDICTMENT.
I'M SURE YOU'VE SEEN THE PHOTOS.
>> SAYING HE COULD IS NOT THE
SAME AS SAYING HE DIDN'T.
>> THERE ARE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IN THE BATHROOM.
IN THE BALLROOM STAGE, AND
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION THAT
HE -- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INFORMATION THAT THE UNITED
STATES SHARES WITH ITS ALLIES,
CRITICAL INFORMATION STREWN ON
THE FLOOR.
DOES THAT LOOK SECURE TO YOU?
>> AGAIN, DANA, THE STANDARD IS
THE STANDARD.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES CAN CLASSIFY AND HE CAN
CONTROL ACCESS TO NATIONAL
SECURITY INFORMATION HOWEVER HE
WANTS.
THAT'S THE STANDARD.
THAT'S THE CONSTITUTION.
THAT'S WHAT THE COURT SAID IN
NAVY VS. EAGAN A 1988 CASE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MORE TIMES
I CAN SAY IT.
IF HE WANTS TO STORE MATERIAL IN
A BOX IN A BATHROOM, IN A BOX ON
THE STAGE, HE CAN DO THAT.
THAT IS JUST WHAT THE LAW AND
THE STANDARD IS.
>> THAT'S NOT --
>> AGAIN, I THINK THIS
UNDERSCORES HOW POLITICAL THIS
WHOLE THING IS.
JACK SMITH -- YOU KNOW HOW
POLITICAL IT IS WHEN THEY
SELECTED JACK SMITH AS SPECIAL
COUNSEL?
I ACTUALLY SAT IN A DEPOSITION
WITH JACK SMITH.
WE DEPOSED HIM ON MAY 29th,
2014, BECAUSE HE WAS LOOKING TO
PROSECUTE PEOPLE WHO WERE
TARGETED BY OBAMA'S IRS.
PEOPLE LOIS LERNER WAS GOING
AFTER.
>> SIR, YOU CAN KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS INDICTMENT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE ALLEGED
OBSTRUCTION IN THE INDICTMENT.
HERE IS WHAT --
>> YOU CAN'T OBSTRUCT WHEN THERE
WAS NOT AN UNDERLYING CRIME.
>> HERE IS WHAT THE INDICTMENT
SAID.
TRUMP DIRECTED NAUTA, HIS
PERSONAL AIDE, TO MOVE BOXES
BEFORE TRUMP ATTORNEY ONE'S JUNE
2nd REVIEW SO MANY BOXES WERE
NOT SEARCHED AND MANY DOCUMENTS
RESPONSIVE TO THE MAY 11
SUBPOENA COULD NOT BE FOUND AND
WERE IN FACT NOT FOUND BY TRUMP
ATTORNEY ONE.
IN PLAIN ENGLISH THIS ALLEGES
TRUMP INSTRUCTED HIS AIDE TO
HELP HIM REMOVE SENSITIVE
DOCUMENTS IN DEFIANCE OF A
FEDERAL SUBPOENA.
A, DOES THAT TROUBLE YOU AND, B,
IF HE THOUGHT HE HAD THE RIGHT
TO HAVE THESE DOCUMENTS, WHY WAS
HE TRYING SO HARD TO HIDE THEM?
>> NO, IT DOESN'T BOTHER ME
BECAUSE AGAIN YOU CAN'T HAVE
OBSTRUCTION OF SOMETHING WHEN
THERE WAS NO UNDERLYING CRIME.
THE STANDARD IS SET.
THE STANDARD IS WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS.
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
HAS THE ABILITY TO CLASSIFY AND
CONTROL ACCESS TO INFORMATION.
THAT'S WHAT THE CONSTITUTION AND
THE COURT HAVE SAID.
YOU CAN'T OBSTRUCT -- YOU CAN'T
OBSTRUCT WHEN THERE IS NO
UNDERLYING CRIME.
>> HE IS NOT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> THAT IS THE FUNDAMENTAL FLAW.
WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT HE
DECLASSIFIED THE MATERIAL.
>> BUT HE SAYS POINT BLANK, ON
TAPE AS PRESIDENT I COULD HAVE
DECLASSIFIED IT.
NOW I CAN'T.
HE SAYS IN HIS OWN WORDS IT'S ON
TAPE AS PART OF THIS INDICTMENT
THAT HE DID NOT DECLASSIFY THE
MATERIAL.
THEREFORE, IT IS CLASSIFIED.
>> DANA, SAYING HE COULD HAVE,
SAYING HE COULD HAVE IS NOT THE
SAME AS SAYING HE DIDN'T.
>> HE SAID NOW I CAN'T.
>> NOW HE CAN'T.
RIGHT.
BECAUSE HE IS NOT PRESIDENT NOW
BUT WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT HE DID
DECLASSIFY IT.
HE SAID THAT.
>> WHICH MEANS WHAT HE WAS
HOLDING WAS CLASSIFIED.
>> NOT IF HE DECLASSIFIED IT
WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR GOODNESS'
SAKE.
>> HE IS SAYING POINT BLANK IN
THIS AUDIO TAPE HE DID NOT
DECLASSIFY IT.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING JUST DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE ON ITS FACE.
>> DANA, WHAT THIS TRULY IS,
DANA, IS AN AFFRONT TO THE RULE
OF LAW.
IT IS AN AFFRONT TO CONSISTENT
APPLICATION OF THE LAW.
YOU HAVE SECRETARY CLINTON WHO
HAD CLASSIFIED MATERIAL ON A
SERVER.
SHE WAS NOT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
SHE WAS SECRETARY CLINTON.
YOU HAVE THAT HAPPEN.
NOTHING HAPPENS TO HER.
WHEN YOU HAVE TWO PEOPLE WHO DO
THE SAME THING AND ONE HAS THE
STANDARD THAT I'VE TALKED ABOUT
BUT THE ONLY ONE WHO GETS
INDICTED IS THE REPUBLICAN, THE
ONLY ONE INDICTED IS THE ONE WHO
WAS PRESIDENT AND DID IT THE
RIGHT WAY.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
THAT IS WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE.
THE OTHER THING THAT TROUBLES ME
ABOUT THIS AND THIS IS TOTAL
AFFRONT TO THE RULE OF LAW IS
THAT JACK SMITH WENT AND GOT THE
PRESIDENT LAWYERS' NOTES.
TALK ABOUT A VIOLATION --
>> I WANT TO GO BACK TO
SOMETHING YOU SAID.
WE WERE GOING BACK ABOUT THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE I WANT
TO POINT OUT WHICH IS THAT THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT SAYS
THAT UPON THE CONCLUSION OF A
PRESIDENT'S TERM IN OFFICE THAT
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT HAVE --
READING HERE, THE ARCHIVIST OF
THE UNITED STATES SHALL ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CUSTODY,
CONTROL, AND PRESERVATION OF AND
ACCESS TO THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS OF THAT PRESIDENT.
IN ENGLISH THAT MEANS THAT EVEN
IF WHAT HE HAD WAS DECLASSIFIED,
IT WAS NOT HIS DOCUMENT.
THEY WERE NOT HIS DOCUMENTS TO
HAVE.
THEY ARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE'S
DOCUMENT.
THAT IS THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS
ACT.
>> I DON'T THINK THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT WAS
MENTIONED ANYWHERE IN THE
INDICTMENT.
44, 45 PAGES.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS MENTIONED.
THERE IS ALWAYS A BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN ADMINISTRATIONS WHEN
THEY LEAVE THE PRESIDENT AND THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
THAT IS JUST NORMAL COURSE OF
BUSINESS.
BUT NOT THIS TIME.
THEY DECIDED ONCE AGAIN THEY
WERE GOING TO GO AFTER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
SOMETHING THE COUNTRY HAS SEEN
THE LEFT DO, SEEN THE DEMOCRATS
DO FOR THE PAST SEVEN YEARS.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION GOING ON.
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION GOING
ON OF JOE BIDEN AS WE SPEAK.
IT IS NOT AS IF THEY JUST WE